Ed I'm sorry to interrupt you we're just
receiving a report that Jeremy Hunt has
been appointed as the UK's new
Chancellor what kind of Chancellor will
he be
oh well I mean who knows Sam I mean it
is certainly a more uh a more
conventional Centrist Choice
um he is less uh libertarian than than
his uh his immediate predecessor clearly
um although he has called in the past
during his when he wanted to become the
conservative leader he's called for a
lot of lower taxes so whether you know
that compromises him at all we will have
to wait and see and again I think the
other question is going to be just
leaving aside what his underlying
policies are
this degree of instability and the fact
that we've kind of gone through so many
different chancellors recently will that
reassure markets or will that kind of
unsettle them looking I'm looking right
now at my kind of terminal and I can see
the pound is starting to rise a touch so
it's up from about uh 1.12 to getting
towards 1.12 and a half and you can see
it there on the top left hand side of
the screen we're going to keep on
watching that because the markets and
their verdicts on what the Prime
Minister has done has been the defining
feature here for this government